what's the deal with airplane peanuts
peanuts
you can always tell you're in a dicey
neighborhood when you see white girls
with cornrows whoa
welcome to Starbucks what can we get
started for you to eat today and you're
like wait what
I just wanted coffee and they're like no
[__]
if you ever meet somebody and they're so
boring you feel like they poisoned you
like
Sledgehammer has been blowing up since
its debut on Netflix last week the new
special has been trending number one in
the United States and Canada after being
released on the 4th of July a lot has
changed her time since his previous
special ball hog came out in 2020 as
he's fresh off one of the biggest comedy
tours of all time spanning two years in
over 180 cities Tom Segura is at the
height of his popularity and the
anticipation for special number five
could not have been higher amongst
comedy fans who were able to sound off
in the comments right here on joke world
and in today's video we're taking a look
at the comedy worlds reaction to Tom
Segura Sledgehammer I will say I did
watch this I never watched specials and
I was like let me see what they're like
and I was watching yours I'm like yeah
this was [__] good I was like turn it
back on like watching it now and I was
like Jesus Christ I watched uh I watched
Sledgehammer last night no thanks and it
was I don't watch specials or I do but I
turn you know you turn them off you turn
them off yeah I was laying right there I
haven't laughed out loud at a special in
a very I was by myself at like midnight
Lane right here like
the the closer made me oh thanks I was
dying dude thank you thank you yeah that
was that was really [__] good man if
you haven't seen it yet
in Sledgehammer ranged from meeting Brad
Pitt getting
a lot about fatherhood family and
marriage the top rated comment according
to YouTube was from really Dave Matthews
mostly stories and completely normal are
still my favorite sagora specials I'm
ready for the next hour from the young
bull and the shaman out of the 500 or so
comments on our post I'd say a good
hundred of them were people saying this
is their favorite Tom special yet
however there were still quite a few
fans who preferred some of Tom's earlier
work this is how we feel 9660 said Tom's
specials are great because he's really
good at portraying a bad person on stage
and can manipulate his words to make an
audience laugh at things they really
shouldn't be ball hog is still my
favorite though I cannot lie this guy
said I think mostly stories will always
be my favorite the timing and
storytelling are masterful Sledgehammer
had Sparks of the storytelling that
mostly stories had I appreciate him
throwing out fan references anyone who
doesn't like it is a g fan Scotty 4473
said ball hog was phenomenal and there
were some funny bits in this one but if
you're a fan of ymh then you've heard
versions of some of these stories
already so that made it a little less
funny for me but he's still the funniest
man in comedy and stamp specials don't
tell the whole story anymore I'd almost
prefer some comedians on podcasts this
podcast argument was honestly the only
legitimate qualm people seem to have
with Sledgehammer feeling like there was
too much of an overlap with jokes from
the podcast being used in this special
this has been a popular concern amongst
comedy fans for a few years now whenever
guys like Tom Theo Tim Dillon or any of
the huge podcast names dropped new hours
thought it was boring not terrible but a
bit disappointing I'm tired of all the
cheap podcast call outs crowd barring in
references to Bert and Garth just to get
the crowd to cheer simple socks said
feels like Shane Gillis and Mark Norman
are some of the only Comics that still
ripe bits and don't just stand on stage
in podcast and this person said as a
huge fan of Tom it's not that good in
comparison to his other specials it felt
like he was playing up for Applause
breaks and a lot of inside jokes I
definitely understand where these
comments are coming from however I will
just say that I watch Sledgehammer with
two people who don't follow comedy
podcasting at all and there's really
only two or three instances where I had
to quickly explain what the reference
meant overall it didn't seem to hinder
their viewing experience too much and
the podcast thing is kind of an
impossible argument too because I feel
like there's always going to be people
who feel disappointed if there was no
references at all see his little ass
come in the room
see the keys and he's like
and I go no don't and he picks them up
and he goes chase me
foreign
I go okay I give him a head start he's
three
when I stand up I see him dip into the
bathroom I'm like no
and when I get there
and I lose my [__]
my wife and I saw him in Long Beach a
day or so after his Brad Pitt encounter
it was awesome he went up for like an
hour and a half with Ryan sickler as his
opener comedy gold he keeps getting
better Mr Man bear pig 1993 said it
surpassed her tied Shane's last special
really really funny I left him edit we
were drunk which is the only way to
watch Comedy or stoned but I was both
speaking of Shane Gillis there were
dozens of comments from Comedy fans
chomping at the bit for Shane's upcoming
special it's a beautiful sight to see
all the dogs fired up I can drink and do
Santa yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
found out it would taped a special this
weekend and oh you did turns out alcohol
might help really yeah the first show I
was like I gotta go into this sharp
silver average average uh in between
sets I was like I'm gonna kill
give me those beers yeah you didn't
really drink that much though didn't you
no not like a lot but like you know four
or five Grease the wheels yeah you had
four or five before the second show yeah
oh dude that's that's that's not not a
lot like that's not a lot that's not
chilling taking five Bud Lights
course of two hours yeah okay that's
nothing for those of you who love
sledgehammer and wished it was longer
great news Tom just put up a deleted
scene from the special this week on his
personal YouTube channel it kind of
reminds me of a store this too you ever
walk into a store and like right away
you're like I should leave like when you
get there
I feel like there's some whenever they
offer you something to drink in a store
that's a sign you know some stores you
walk into and they're like would you
like still or sparkling water and you're
like I left something in the car I'll be
right back but
this is one of my favorite specials in a
long time Tom segor is one of my
favorite comedians so the expectations
were high I was honestly a little
nervous that it would disappoint but it
did not I would give it a 9 out of ten
highly recommend guest spots from last
week The Joe Rogan Experience had on Tom
Segura Tommy buns was also on Matt and
Shane's secret podcast as well as are
you garbage ymh talked with Adam
Friedland Chris's Stefano was a guest on
Whiskey Ginger but yeah they learned
about that my daughter my the other day
was funny my daughter came home this is
what Catholic School on Staten Island
she came home
and she had a little like work coloring
worksheet and they're learning about
like gender roles and stuff and you have
like you know like yeah drag shows and
public schools in New York and they're
teaching kids about masturbation my kid
Catholic School in Staten Island they
came home she came home it was it was a
coloring sheet and it had a it you were
coloring in who's a man and who's a
woman and they had the man had a tool
belt and a hammer at a br at a wall like
a construction worker and the woman had
a mop and was at a stove and so on and
so like it's just like they don't even
care they just lean into like this is
what a woman does yeah this sort of bad
does and nobody complained but what was
he really at he was at the border yeah
yeah it said U.S Mexico
Tony this week was with Trevor Wallace
and Brian Simpson two bears one cave was
Bert and Tom Tom and Bert Brian Callan
went on take her shoes off and Mateo
Lane was a guest on flagrant this past
weekend with Theo Vaughn talked with
Adam DeVine taste buds battled Grimace
vs Barney Joe DeRosa was on the honest
Papa's hour Dr Drew went on the Honeydew
Greg Warren was a guess when we might be
drunk Greg Fitzsimmons was on first date
Fred Armisen was on the blocks podcast
you know what dude posted a best of 2023
and Margaret Cho was on tigerbelly as
far as new stand-up specials that are
either out right now or coming out soon
obviously we've talked about it a bunch
already in this video but Tom segor's
brand new hour Sledgehammer is out right
now on Netflix it's hilarious go check
it out other new specials to keep an eye
on Kevin Hart reality check is out right
now on peacock Mark Norman's new hours
coming out two weeks from today on July
25th and Rob Schneider woke up America
is also out right now the CEO of United
Airlines last month the CEO he announced
of all the hiring for all the new pilots
that are coming up this year all the
hiring for the new pilots the main focus
is going to be diversity
what
we just posted a new video recapping the
funniest podcast moments from the month
of June so be sure to check that out
right after this video also let me know
in the comments what you thought of
sledgehammer and what new specials
you're most looking forward to we'll
definitely be making recap videos
similar to this one for both Mark and
Shane's upcoming specials so if you want
your comment read in a future video be
sure to subscribe to joke world right
now and if you're really feeling wild
you can even follow us on Instagram
thanks for watching
at joke world
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out